how is it that we've gone from
what do you think would have happened 40
years ago
if something like this was done if they
had an event like this with Children
what do you think the governments would
have done I don't think the governments
would have been involved because we
still had culture then we still had a
culture where parents would have been
responsible and they would have shown up
and whoever was doing that would have
had a very sad day you know you think
people in the community would show up
and there would be a riot yeah so baby
steps you're I think you're mistaken
this isn't baby steps this is total and
complete surrender yeah that's it the
fact that we've gone from a society that
says we won't allow this to a society
that says well I guess I can put your
liquor license that means we've
retreated and surrendered the fight
completely and and this is rotten
Sanders being like I guess I'll do
something I don't know I I don't want to
believe that it's a surrender